you're part of the power Universe now is
there power the universe or snowfall
what are we even talking about bro like
you don't want me to answer that
question because look first of all I I
love fifth Fitness fifth is a beautiful
yeah just let me do my [__] bro don't
let me get because look I'm not scared
of getting fired and that's why
everybody that's why I don't do podcasts
right but I'm [__] with you so I'ma
tell you the truth 50 no I love him and
he's built Something Beautiful he
creates Stars yeah for sure movies don't
create Stars right like TV creates
stories yeah and 50 be doing that so
shout out to him in my personal opinion
power did something interesting
internationally and something that was
accessible for a large amount of people
but bar for bar like what we talking
about snowfall is a bar for bar snowfall
is a different level it's one of the uh
yeah now if you ask me snowfall versus
raising Canaan we gonna have some
conversations okay because raising
Canaan is top tier filmmaking like shout
out to Sasha Penn is different over
there shout out to like my whole cast is
like look ain't look it's tough because
amen
um dancing you know Gail Bean like they
really go crazy Isaiah like everybody
over there go crazy even their co-stars
like right even the who plays damson's
mom is a legendary actor right even the
doodle plate is that there's a legendary
but when I talk about patina Miller
I love damson damson is one of the best
young actors we have patina Miller Tony
award-winning Miller she's she might be
one of the best when it's all said and
done ever wow and we and everybody
around her Haley Kilgore Tony nominated
crying every episode that's some real
ass stem Tony's is them real acting I'm
just it's different bro and you know we
got then we got then we got London Brown
who's giving a seller performance then
we have Makai Curtis I'm the youngest
thing on our cast Makai is murdering
everyone in the power Universe respect
to everybody else Makai is acting when
you look at him you think he 50. crazy
that's a Suburban kid yeah he ain't
nothing 50 about him in real life y'all
hear him be like that's 50. right it's
different on that side the texture the
clothing
um Frank who does our clothing is is
different right the texture is different
if you watch bar for bar
ah it's close power might have them with
raising Canyon raising Canaan I think so
I gotta be honest with you I I am the
most unhipped to the power Universe
person alive it's not your fault I'm
gonna tell you the truth I just never
got Stars I never got the streaming and
then I'm like a wire dude bro I never
watched power until I was only yeah
facts I just I always like I started to
watch season one right when you get into
it you're hooked so I watched the first
two episodes of the first season of
power and when the chick was like
playing with herself in the back seat
crazy that's the first episode bro I was
just like I was like imagine watching
I'm like like I swear by the wire that's
my favorite show ever because it's one
of the best shows of all time and then
snowfall just sucked me in bro pause
that [__] was amazing but if we're being
real like my mom use also the wire is
Leaps and Bounds better than snowballs
well I think the wire is the best show
ever it's top tier what it's literally I
think it's the wire go ahead and then
Sopranos and Breaking Bad okay so I
would go see I don't see me I go The
Wire
and then I'd go I just think it's the
wire and everything else I think that we
have to Subs we have to yeah essentially
it's like everything else not even worth
it but it's the wire and then everything
else yeah Rome was pretty great though
what was that wrong oh you know I never
watched Rome that was on HBO too right
HBO got got hitters bro they got some
all of them man HBO for whatever reason
whatever's in the water over there man
they don't [__] around when it comes to
their shows in the original one Game of
Thrones was crazy no it's crazy homicide
um uh the the original Network show that
the creators of the wire created which
was homicide something
um was actually one of the best shows on
television for years and I never watched
it but I heard it it was hard and West
Wing hard you know Awesome's dope that's
Oz was dope like yeah they got hitters
like but if we really talking about it
snowfall is really fun and it has great
actors you know but when it comes to the
wire it's different so the thing about
snowfall is let me know because you
weren't on the show at this time when
the episode happens last season
and they rebounded with the episode
where everybody was [__] up at the
wedding I love that episode but when the
episode happens where they get locked up
in the basement and there's a [__]
was it a grizzly bear or a tiger or
something that's when they lost me when
that happened I was just like yeah it
went too far but but this is what
happens look I'm not gonna speak too
heavy on that show because there's too
many people I love and care about
benefiting from that show and until I'm
as big as that show right I have nothing
to say about that show but love the
writing out of that was really shaky
that was ridiculous and everybody can
agree that was ridiculous so let's just
leave it there because you never saw
that and I like the way it ended I
thought it ended well season five was a
nice which is hard to do for a
television season four was tough though
when that happened I was just like wait
a minute I'ma say no comment for it
there's a random white dude living in
the hood with a [__] tiger in his
[__] basement bro no comment and they
escaped listen I think you are speaking
for the people yeah but I also don't
want to make this a snowfall show
there's my wife
my wife she loved that [__] but my wife
like loves you know she likes like
[__] but that's what I mean is like
nobody bro let's keep it a bug nobody
watched The Wire when it was first out
except for drug dealers nobody sold
drugs and critics it was like the nerdy
show to watch it's almost yes succession
right now yes and then years later I
feel like finally the the general
population are like getting hip to
succession where like the TV nerds have
kind of been hit for like four or five
years yeah they're the early adopters
it's like knowing the wire was like that
yeah it had to end for people to be like
let me go back and get the DVD it's the
Great American novel right it's the [__]
that everybody knows is great but it's
too long so no nobody read it
was like my favorite character in TV one
of the best ever yeah and like in my
opinion like yeah and there's you know
like I said I I don't want to make this
that show but in real life I think
snowfall did it it was a great
entertainment did his job it was very
entertaining one of the most
entertaining shows on television hands
down in depths is one of the most times
people and so was aiming there how
involved um is 50 in like the day-to-day
like do you like here he sets it up he
set it up he was very involved day to
day when we begin and get the show
rolling but then it's like bro I set it
up y'all got to do what you got to do
and really truly it becomes the
mechanizations of everybody who's in key
positions behind the scenes such as
Sasha Japan
um you know we got to attached has he
listened to the music have you sent him
any records oh 50
um 50 no what's up 50 know what's up but
he like you know we gonna see what's
going on that'd be crazy you get 50 at
least do a skit or something I know 50
my dog but you know what bro I'm not one
who asked for handouts I'd rather the
homies like when they peep it be like
wait I want to be part of this yeah
that's better for me I don't want no you
know unless somebody said because I feel
like when you ask you know first of all
everybody's uncomfortable because like
bro like I'm sure a million people
asking you but if I show you what I'm
doing and you [__] with it then it's
genuine you [__] with it like you call
it hey this you don't you don't suck
come on the show